mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
start with the trapezoid where these two
sides are congruent the trapezoid has
angles of 80 degrees 80 degrees 100
degrees and 100 degrees
now join congruent trapezoids to form a
closed ring
how many trapezoids are needed in total
to form a closed ring
this is said to be one of the toughest
questions asked on the sat which i saw
on a thread on quora
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
we can actually simulate it on the
computer quite nicely we can actually
place trapezoids adjacent to each other
until we form a closed ring
we then just need to count the total
number of trapezoids
and there we go we get our answer of 18.
however you won't be able to use
computer software on the test so how do
we solve it using pencil and paper
well let's place adjacent trapezoids and
then calculate this exterior angle
around the closed ring
since we have an 80 degree angle here
this exterior angle will be 180 minus 80
minus 80 which simplifies to be 20
degrees
now we'll use a property of exterior
angles in a polygon
the sum of the exterior angles will be
equal to 360 degrees
since one exterior angle is 20 degrees
we have n times 20 degrees is equal to
360 and therefore n is equal to 18
and that will be our answer which
exactly matches what we found before
what's more is we can use this method in
the video to solve similar problems so i
challenge you to this variation of the
problem where one angle in the trapezoid
is 60 degrees
and i challenge you to another variation
where one angle is 75 degrees how many
trapezoids will be needed to form a
closed ring
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you